y aquí tenemos un par de en anti hombros
del lado izquierdo tenemos de carbón y
del lado derecho ese carbón a estos dos
compuestos tienen el mismo punto de
fusión el mismo punto de ebullición y la
misma densidad pero también tienen
algunas diferencias importantes la ere
carbón a se encuentra en el aceite de
hierbabuena la ere carbón a huele a
hierbabuena mientras que la ese carbón
se encuentra en el aceite de comino
huele a comino es muy impresionante como
nuestra nariz puede decirnos la
diferencia entre estos dos enantiómero
otra diferencia importante es su
actividad óptica verán los enantiómero
presentan un comportamiento diferente
cuando se les expone a la luz polarizada
les explicaré
aquí tenemos luz no polarizada que
normalmente es una lámpara de sodio por
eso escucharán hablar de la línea t de
sodio que es una longitud de onda de 589
nanómetros ahora esta luz no polarizada
pasará a través de un filtro y observen
que este filtro tiene unas rendijas
verticales así que solamente la luz que
se encuentre en el plano vertical podrá
pasar a través de los filtros verticales
es decir nosotros tenemos un plano de
luz polarizada y este plano pasará a
través de un tubo este es el tubo del
polar y metro tubo del polar y metro
adentro de este tubo tenemos una
solución de un compuesto ópticamente
activo imaginen que aquí tenemos nuestra
solución el compuesto está disuelto en
algo ahora el plano polarizado rotará al
chocar con el compuesto imagínense que
este plano que inicialmente se encuentra
vertical empieza a rotar y entre más
choca con las moléculas más rota así que
cuando sale del tubo se encuentra en un
ángulo diferente al que tenía antes y
bueno después tenemos el analizador este
es el analizador
supongamos que nuestros ojos se
encuentran aquí estamos observando el
analizador y digamos que el analizador
empezó con las rendijas verticales justo
como las del filtro pero así no podría
pasar este plano de luz así que
necesitamos rotar el analizador como lo
tenemos en el dibujo para que el plano
de luz pueda pasar
así las rendijas van en esta dirección y
el plano podrá pasar a través de ellas
entonces necesitamos rotar el analizador
hacia la derecha para que el plano pueda
pasar y este ángulo que llamaremos alfa
es la rotación observada rotación
observad
en este caso necesitamos rotar el
analizador hacia la derecha supongamos
que empezamos en posición vertical y el
plano de luz al chocar con el compuesto
roto hacia la derecha esto significa que
también rotamos el analizador hacia la
derecha por lo tanto tenemos una
rotación observada positiva que también
se conoce como rotación de estro gira
destro gira
pero qué pasaría si el plano de luz
rotará hacia la izquierda
bueno nuevamente empezamos en posición
vertical pero ahora el plano de luz roto
en esta dirección así que necesitamos
rotar el analizador hacia la izquierda
la rotación observada es negativa a esta
rotación se le conoce como elevo gira
elevo gira ahora la rotación observada
alfa depende del número de moléculas
golpeadas por la luz polarizada por
ejemplo supongamos que aumentamos la
concentración dibujaré más puntos esto
significa que la luz rotará aún más
empieza en posición vertical pero choca
con más moléculas así que al rotar más
cambiará la rotación observada entonces
si duplicamos la concentración
duplicamos la rotación observada y bueno
otra forma de cambiar la rotación
observada es cambiando la longitud del
tubo
vamos a llamarle el si mantenemos la
misma concentración pero duplicamos la
longitud del tubo duplicaremos la
rotación observada porque cuando el tubo
es más largo la luz toca con más
moléculas ok ya con estas ideas de
rotación observada concentración y
longitud del tubo tratemos de obtener
una ecuación vamos a ver tenemos la
rotación observada alfa que se mide en
grados porque si algo rota podemos medir
el ángulo entonces medimos este ángulo
de rotación en grados y vamos a dividir
la rotación observada entre la
concentración que tenemos adentro del
tubo la concentración la mediremos en
gramos por mililitro
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por la
longitud del tubo el que se mide en
decímetros con esto podemos calcular la
rotación específica que se escribe como
alfa entre corchetes
esta es la rotación específica
y lo más importante es que esta rotación
específica es una constante la rotación
observada puede cambiar dependiendo de
la concentración y la longitud del tubo
pero al dividir la rotación observada
entre la concentración por la longitud
obtenemos una rotación específica que al
ser constante es muy útil porque podemos
buscar las rotaciones específicas de
ciertos compuestos por ejemplo podemos
buscar la rotación específica de la ese
carbono bueno aunque también depende de
la temperatura y la longitud de onda por
eso necesitamos especificar la
temperatura aquí y la longitud de onda
acá para la ese carbono a 20 grados lo
escribiré por acá
la rotación específica de la ese carbono
a 20 grados celsius y usando la línea de
de sodio es igual a más 61
esta es la rotación específica de la ese
carbono en general la rotación
específica
y no tiene unidades por eso no escribí
algo más aunque algunas veces pueden
llegar a encontrarlos en grados pero voy
a quitarlo porque los grados se usan en
la rotación observada así es cómo verán
la rotación específica
ya vimos que la s carbono tiene una
rotación específica de más 61 entonces
este enantiómero es de estrógeno porque
tenemos una rotación positiva por eso
tenemos este signo positivo pero por
otro lado la r carbono tiene una
rotación específica de menos 61 así que
éste enantiómero es nuevo giro tenemos
una rotación negativa y por eso ponemos
este signo negativo
ahora observen la diferencia en las
rotaciones específicas los enantiómero
sostienen rotaciones específicas que son
de la misma magnitud en este caso
tenemos 61 y 61 pero son de diferente
signo este es negativo y este es
positivo
louis pasteur fue el primero en
descubrir esta relación seguramente fue
muy interesante
ahora quiero señalar que la
configuración r&s no tiene nada que ver
con el signo negativo o positivo el
hecho de que este sea ese no tiene nada
que ver con que sea positivo r&s solo es
la configuración que se le asigna al
centro kieran mientras que los signos
positivos y negativo de las rotaciones
específicas se determinan
experimentalmente como ya vimos los
compuestos gira les son ópticamente
activos pero los compuestos a quirales
no lo son